it really puts things into perspective
i'm in the last
chapter of my life and here we are
camping in our backyard
you guys camp oh my god we've been
camping i saw you on a beach too i was
soaking there wasn't a beach that was in
a tent in our backyard
oh wait the beach yes we didn't go to
the beach
so i'll tell you something all right
i know what it's like to be alone like
on that show
we tested his theory about george
remember how you were like oh
he's going to last two days you are not
wrong
no that's oh god you're so you're so
beautiful
oh my god so beautiful yeah michael
grass
um alone all right so
when you're sleeping in a tent in your
backyard and the reason why we did we
have to do this is because
you know because of the flooding the cat
like we got new
hardwood and floors and they had they
put this [ __ ] um
really potent um shine on it or whatever
what's it called
it was coding but then it wasn't the
they didn't use the non-toxic one that i
asked them to use and so they didn't
give us any warning and so
when we came when we went upstairs i was
like i told the guy i was like
is this safe to inhale he was like no
you should probably stay in a hotel
and this is like at nine at night and we
were like we have nowhere to go i don't
know where to go
right they didn't tell us and when you
walked in the house your eyes would burn
burn
your lungs it was terrible about your
animals we
put them away yeah so then um we
were we got in a fight almost we did
kind of get in a fight we did get into a
fight yeah
i like i'll sleep in the garage and
you're like no we're gonna go to my
mom's and you know it was a whole thing
well here's the thing he wanted to sleep
in a garage with no windows and the
smell was already empty
yeah going in through here so i was like
oh my god he's gonna wake up dead
you know what i mean like i didn't think
that this was not to me this is not a a
good place like there's no windows no
place for the
for the toxins to or you know the fumes
to exit
anyway um she goes we're gonna fight and
then she's like
i i think she said let's camp back in
the backyard
well i said let's go to my mom's because
she has an extra room and yeah
i can't sleep in her mom's house there's
no way this is gonna happen yeah i just
sit on the couch all day
all night um so we pitched a tent in the
backyard
yeah we got all the dogs and stuff in
there yeah we it was me
jules bobby the three dogs inside the
team inside a tent
okay so many how big is it ted
it's a it's a nice more nice yeah yeah
but it's a tent and we're not no
sleeping bags it was fun because we
brought
in the we that's where we watched a
netflix documentary yeah but those
korean pads we put these korean sleep
pads down there
and then put some sheets on there and
then it's like three in the morning and
i'm laying
in this [ __ ] tent right
and it's like they're asleep i don't
know how the [ __ ]
right yeah i got a dog on my face dog
between my legs right
and people are snoring and i'm just
sitting there and
then all of a sudden i realize that
there's no blankie
i have no blankie you're gonna freeze to
death yeah so i'm kind of getting cold
too and i just knew i made a decision in
my mind
you're not sleeping in here you're
[ __ ]
you're absolutely [ __ ] so i just i
went i just laid there
until the sun came up you didn't sleep
no he didn't sleep at all
what was the fear of sleep and i could
see that that all of a sudden like
as the sun rises right then the tent
becomes brighter yeah
i listen boom it's day right and i'm
still
laying there you know it was terrible
the [ __ ] but that has nothing to do with
surviving it alone and alone they're
offering you money
yeah but it's it's also competitive
right it's also televised those are
three things
so me knowing that it's televised number
two
me knowing that it's competitive like if
it's me against these guys
i have to show face right and i was so i
would do it
i would last but there's nothing at
stake
so i'm not gonna [ __ ] sleep and i'm
not gonna sleep in there again yeah
but it's so comfy it's not for you
it's not comfy for me i can't believe
you stayed up the whole time the whole
time i didn't sleep
at all and then what happened did i fall
asleep again
during the day like for like 30 minutes
during the day i took a little quick nap
yeah yeah but it's also like it really
wasn't
it wasn't good conditions because this
is over the weekend when we were in
triple digits
so we couldn't even sleep past you know
8 a.m yeah it was triple
digits so then um but we were back in
the rooms you know
in the house and it's like um yeah
camping is
you know i don't know i don't know why
people do it wait but you said that we
would
you said that we would go camping if you
had your own tent
yeah if i had my own four-man tent that
i could sleep
is there a tent that has blackout shades
that would be perfect that'd be perfect
for me
there isn't yeah but what i would do is
i would get like a downy downy um
uh sleeping bag right the one with the
little you know i mean the hood part
yeah and i would
get i think i think i'll be fine yeah
yeah well let's try it then
yeah i have to go buy those things i'll
buy it for you yeah
hey guys we're gonna take a really quick
break to share this brand new
juicy sponsor with you we